there's a point buried there that I want
your audience to understand we I had to
fight it all the way
I think I think that I'm I'm saying the
cost of the total cost of that one deal
1.5 mil
1.5 million to do the right thing
cost me 1.5 million and what did I get I
got a check for 15 grand four years
later in crickets I would not and I'm
not complaining I'm not a victim I don't
want your pity I don't want your
sympathy I am trying to make a point do
you know how many late night dinners
how many car rides how many airplane
trips away from my loved ones that I had
to take to raise that money to pay those
lawyers and by the way more power to the
lawyers it's the free market they
deserve to get paid a thousand dollars
an hour and they won
but the price that has to be paid
is is so Central to the journalism
itself you can't tell the story without
also paying that price and nobody gets
that